this is how we all dress over there now
what would you like a rap about
don't laugh this is your thinking time
brains
is that what you said
as in cerebellar not the welsh beer
brand
cool good just in case we've got any
taffies in i don't know
brains what about brains what interests
you about brains
is it's kind of meta that your brain was
like make it rap about me
[Music]
cool
egotistical brains
let's come to this side of the room ah
you guys weren't ready you thought you
had all the time there it's like when
the teacher's like we're going to do the
test in reverse alphabetical order
was that just my teachers okay
i was turner so i hated that um yeah
people against the wall so far we got
pg
oh mr pg well in doing press for this
show i rapped about mr pg on the radio
and i don't rap about the same
suggestion twice
so
oh we wanted you to rap about our
[ __ ] freakish clown who stands
outside this
i was like
the guy was like hey would you wrap up
mr pg i was like i'll just look my
wikipedia's like you don't want to do
that you will not sleep again
so i can't take mr pg because i don't i
don't ever do the same rep twice so i
need something fresh and new
awesome
austin powers that's racist man you just
saw me
austin powers rk
austin powers egotistical brains that
wasn't from that section against the
walls so sexually against the wall you
still gotta hit me with one
you say snowstorm great ventriloquism
people against the wall
snowstorm ventriloquism austin powers
egotistical brains right we've got the
middle of the room this is the hub this
is the big old big old bunch so if you
are on this side of the middle of the
room would you like a
wrap that's what i like
that's what i like
a viking who is self-conscious about his
boat size yeah it's funny cause really
we're thinking about his penis
and now people over here i know
technically we go from down here but
maybe come over to the back on this side
what you guys want to wrap up
okay so there were two one of them
immediately bailed out when they heard
the other person saying the inner
workings of a pulp mill
which is a great suggestion but what was
the one that you kind of was about to
say and didn't get to say
okay yeah it's worse than it
so let's recap this let's recap we've
got brains and they're egotistical we've
got snowstorm and maybe ventriloquism in
that we've got um
austin powers the inner workings of a
pulp mill and a viking self-conscious
about is boat size and not condoms so
this lovely people the prince george
playhouse i'm sure is the first time
this illustrious venue has ever seen a
british man freestyle rap and depending
on how this goes maybe the last time
it's ever seen a british man freestyle
rap
we'll go with uh we'll go with that
number b yeah let's use that b i feel
like these suggestions fit that let's
drop that beat unless uh let's have some
fun oh yeah i feel this you guys feel
this
yeah
but i mean like you guys feel this
yeah you feel it hell yeah from my
austin powers man down here that's me
flicking me the v's like that that's
effective in my country you know that
space is like this but you were like nah
cool
i like it it's gonna be [ __ ] sick
just be too long on the intro but don't
worry
give the b signs shouting out please
austin power on the screen look at those
teeth michael myers i know he's from
north america he's kind of sexy aspire
with the chest hair you're best aware dr
evil and minnie me one of those tall
ones
he's walking in the room like oh
shagalicious
baby with the massive breath if he did
this today he'd be branded a pest
basically sexually harassing solving all
the crime while he's doing gram acid but
that's the whole thing i don't poor
scorn on spies like austin powers or
jason bourne i'm kind of blinded to the
skill like i'm in a snow storm cold
outside so i want to get warm going
inside like a fire with the twigs
looking at my dummy because i'm a
ventriloquist i'm like oh off we go make
your mouth down low when outside it
snows
wish to that he's the mascot he's the
symbol of your town if a snowstorm came
and blowed him down you would gather all
around you would get a little census
saying please sign this we erect this
back up make him 10 feet cold talk about
a viking who's ever so small in the boat
region i'm not saying nevers he'd be
from norway getting it together in the
wintertime off to some village to find
some ladies to rape and pillage and it's
okay to rape as long as you pillage
isn't that weird yeah there's some
spillage on the ship because the crew
deck isn't that large the big viking
comes in who's in charge like yeah son
you need to get a longer one otherwise
you don't want feeling a condom wait
that makes really no sense i see the
dragon's head and i start to get tense
and i'm mentioning this hard to read
coming
speed
microphone cable busting now that's okay
acapella when i scream and shout then
i'm fighting thoughts with
tonight only one more thing got to spill
let me talk about the inner workings of
a pulp mill wait one sec forgot it again
i got reminded of my egotistical brain
he's like chris you just skip me move
past do the pulp mill first said the
best to last i'm like okay so many
rhymes i will tell em make you know the
paper then use my cerebellum i'm writing
it down we can all see it's mr p be like
a model of trees cause we're cutting
them down with the chainsaw i get it
over there put it on the mills floor i
start mixing it round in the chipper it
goes it's like the death at the end of
fargo i know that's north dakota not in
your country but if you want a little
bit of pulp come to me i can help you
the paper friction the only
pulp fiction but back here over to the
brain once you've had one you'll never
feel the same again people say brain yes
i really like you and i do why because i
got the high iq it's ever so good it'd
be rocking my world i got that nice pink
fleshy thing in my skull there we go
people say the brain might be crap but
it's the thing that's bringing you the
freestyle rap boom